this looks for all intents and purposes
at the beginning looks just like this
doesn't it you can see I've got two
sides and I have an angle right and I
want to find an angle so I'm going to
have a pair of a side angle and another
pair of signing I can use the same rules
okay so I begin just by writing a
formula ok on your side a1a cyan be on B
and then it started for this guy and
everything's business is usual so far ok
what's the one that I want I'll write
that first that's d feo here so sign of
DF eight what's the side opposite it's
seven you can see it there pretty good
and so that gives me an indication of
where I go next which is the other angle
42 and the last remaining piece of
information mainly five okay everything
still as it was before I'll just take
that seven over to the other side so now
you have something to pop into your
calculator right can someone give me and
read out maybe four or five decimal
places for what you're getting on the
right hand side over there 35 35 3 how
convenient ok so just pause there right
looks good I'm it this line here right
I'm pretty close right so let's now hit
shift to your sine inverse right and I'm
going to get an angle that I expect for
DF eight right I give it to me with some
decimal places and then we round off can
someone give me some maybe two or three
decimal places 51 hey Doc okay so we
know what that approximates to
approximately I will just go dearest
agree okay now again pause right we'll
do what we did over here does that
answer like this enter does it um does
it make sense does it look like what
you'd expect do you think I'm trying to
say that this guy over here is
70 degrees right ? I think it looks fine
it looks okay right we've got smaller
angle smaller side be great beagles big
aside no problems okay well there is one
tiny little problem okay i want you to
for a second forget all of these
triangles that i've just drawn okay i
want you to imagine if this was the
question that i gave you right just just
that line there you remember we started
off looking at this guy okay it's like
some trig ratio of some number then I
said have this one sultry ratio some
number now for both of these guys we
went through this process like 10
minutes ago you gave me two answers for
both of them right two answers and of
course you get two answers because you
draw the graph draw the graph you get
two answers so therefore if I given you
this question I know it has some icky
decimals in a bath no big deal it just
makes the angle big loss more if I gave
you this question you ought to expect
not one answer but two there are always
two turning up or sometimes there every
three okay so hold on a second let's uh
let's use put this now this time because
we should practice you too here's my
here my quadrants okay sign is yeah I
got that wrong 53 53 okay what is it no
I it's it's a completely different
desert haha that's okay is this angle
still yeah you're a different with froyo
k ki tomorrow's get 993 67 okay thank
you all right someone else should pick
them that's all right no problem ok we
have it right now now still the same
principle that's probably the same sign
is positive isn't it see that's not a
negative number like this okay so which
quadrant semi in first and second one
270 degrees which answer is that that's
the first quadrant angle right that's
the first quarter angle so I should be
expecting a second quadrant angle how do
i find second quadrant angles
I take the UH the supplement of this
angle right so not only 17 but 180 take
away 17 okay it's just like I looked at
before you can see how these skills fit
together in our incidents I actually
have Sonia Ruiz or a hundred and ten
that's the supplement okay now if you
look at this right I said 70 degrees ?
could 110 degrees also work now on my
diagram it doesn't look like it could
work but you guys know all the time like
every diagram you see in like a test
with a textbook they're like not to
scale not to scale right just use the
just use the measurements the actual
numbers that are on there and the shape
of it is just a general guide okay now
if it were a hundred ten more but this
triangle actually look like mmm hundred
turns up it's an obtuse angle why it's a
it's second quadrant right so it's going
to look something like this I guess
something more like that okay ish right
so this actually works it's totally
plausible right and so being the fact
that it's kind of ambiguous whether it's
this angle or that angle right it could
be either of them what we call this
thing you can put this in big big
colorful letters right this is called
the ambiguous case for the same room the
same rule is really cool because it
shows us this relationship between the
sides and angles right you make one
logger you've got the other one so I
make one big on get this one longer or
vice versa but it has this little kind
of trap door in it right because of the
way sign looks the curve it looks like
this okay so if we ask ourselves when is
this true you draw your line through and
you get 12 solutions ok so i will give
you those two oceans and they both work
ok so it's ambiguous
therefore your default should be to say
i'll get one answer it could be the
other way it could be the other one so I
should just write that down for sure it
could be either right